[Music]
in an age long forgotten preceding the
dark chapters and high rules distant
past three golden goddesses created the
world granting it physical form
autonomous life forms and lost who
uphold after the divine task was done
these spectral beings left this plane of
existence leaving only a symbol of their
power behind in the form of the almighty
Triforce however upon their departure a
more sinister force was unleashed as
well a curse was cast upon the
unexpected inhabitants of this newly
created reality a wave of dark cypher
rippled through Hyrule investing any
living soul it could find seizing
control of the neurons of its hosts and
suppressing their reasoning memory and
advanced motor functions the result was
a population stuck in strange behavior
loops repeating the same lines in
cohesive speech patterns and loss of the
ability to perform advanced motion
standing frozen in place or cursed at
walk the same path over and over for no
damn reason
additionally time bubbles were created
around the big population centers across
the land preventing time from flowing
naturally unless unobserved turning
quantum theory on its head or you know
it might have had something to do with
the limitations of primitive hardware
[Music]
MPC's or non-player characters have
historically been rather crucial in the
Zelda series handing out important hints
items or advice however in terms of
their AI if you can even call it that
there wasn't exactly anything special
about them with most of them glued to
the ground and endlessly repeating the
same animation in lines in that regard
the early NPCs basically functioned as
glorified signposts with the passing of
each new iteration in the Zelda series
we've slowly seen NPCs acting more and
more like actual people Majora's Mask
with its three day time cycle allowed
for richer character development with
inhabitants having actual schedules and
daily routines and I'd argued that to
this day Clock Town is still one of the
most believable fictional towns ever
constructed the Wind Waker and Twilight
Princess saw NPCs walking around going
on daily strolls indulging in gossip or
going on like a thieving missions
however one thing was missing from these
games the inhabitants of Hyrule or
termina rarely left the safety of their
respective towns or cities characters
talked about it telling stories of their
travels or days out at sea but we almost
never got to actually see it happen with
our own eyes in the Wind Waker we barely
saw any friendly ships out on the open
waters or sailing from island to island
in general it was quite rare to meet a
fellow adventurer out on the road making
the world feel less realistic and
connected how do these shops keep up
their supplies how do people travel
between towns and how the hell is this
guy still in business breath of the wild
made a radical change in this department
despite the world being enormous in
decline and more dangerous than it's
ever been before we can meet many
different characters out on the road
people risking their lives to gather
resources merchants travelling between
towns travellers and adventurers going
in and out of stables treasure hunters
looking for fortunes archeologists and
researchers studying different aspects
of Hyrule distant past now for link this
is of course nothing special as he is
missed a hero man savior of worlds but
it's refreshing to see other inhabitants
traversing the landscape it all
contributes to making Hyrule despite its
broken stay
feel like a world being lived in which
brings us to the main subject of the
video throughout Hyrule we can find
plenty of NPCs who have chosen to leave
the safety of their village life behind
to set up camp out there in the wild
each with their own personal reasons
whether it's running a trading business
a spiritual quest or just a general
thirst for adventure some set up camp in
very remote locations others are idiots
and camp right in the path of traveling
becau blends and how kidding this guy
gets his ass kicked on a daily basis
tests move your camp dude however more
interestingly sometimes you will stumble
upon an abandoned campsite with its
occupant no longer around some of these
can be found in rather interesting areas
just the fact that you can reach a
desolate and remote location and find
out someone's already been there has a
feeling of a mystique around it it makes
you curious about who this person is or
was what happened to them and where are
they now
are they even still alive in some cases
only the remnants of a campfire remain
yet sometimes we can find other
materials as well and even a tent still
completely intact so let's go over some
of the most interesting spots found
across Hyrule the many bridges found
around Hyrule don't have anything
interesting underneath not even the
great bridge of hylia the only one that
does have something noteworthy is
Kakariko bridge there is a small
abandoned campsite with a cooking pot a
roasted bass some boxes and food
leftovers and a chest containing ice
arrows now it's not so much the campsite
itself that's interesting but rather the
location now I don't know if this is
what they were going for but I'd like to
think that this is a reference to the
man under the bridge in a Link to the
Past if you visit him by swimming under
the bridge he will grant you one of four
empty bottles you can obtain in the game
so most veterans are familiar with this
guy the fact that none of the other
bridges have anything of interest
underneath them and this campsite is
just randomly here feels like a nod to
this particular location whoever was
camping here previously they are no
longer around to hand out bottles to
strangers
if you've seen my video about the low
male labyrinths you may remember me
mentioning that there's a camp site in
the eastern section of the maze near the
outer wall this location has intrigued
me since who other than link would be
daring enough to venture into such a
large complex and dangerous structure
all by themselves well I think I found
the answer to that question to the
southeast not too far from the labyrinth
at the snow field stable we find an old
man by the name of mountain he shares a
childhood story of two of his friends
Harry and Mary who both disappeared and
were never heard from again
Mary allegedly slipped off a cliff while
they were looking for the entrance to
the Forgotten temple and in all
probability didn't survive the long fall
down into Tanager Canyon the tale of
Harry is where it gets interesting in
his younger years Moncton and Harry went
out to play in the maze ignoring the
warning of the adults who said not to go
near it as it was too dangerous one day
Moncton urged Harry to travel deeper
into the maze as a test of courage after
which he was never seen or heard from
again
so could this campsite belong to Harry
who after being lost inside the
confusing and complex corridors of this
massive structure had to rest and regain
his strength ah but see there's one
piece of information I've left out of
the story at the end of the story about
Mary's unfortunate fate Moncton reveals
the real truth and states that although
both were never seen or heard from again
two of their descendants are in the
stall right outside that's right Harry
and Mary weren't actually people and
Moncton reveals that his only friends
growing up in this remote location were
horses so with this information we can
make a strong assumption that whoever
was camping inside the maze was in all
probability making a desperate attempt
to look for Harry this could have been
Moncton himself although he does mention
that he was just a kid when the incident
occurred so either he was one badass kid
or it was one of the stable owners most
likely his father who went out to look
for that precious horse while inside the
maze he may have gotten lost himself and
was forced to halt his search and spend
the night within the walls of the
freezing north low male average
harry was never seen again and probably
either died from hypothermia starvation
or fell prey to the red lizalfos who
made their home inside these walls one
interesting detail that may or may not
have a connection to this tale at night
around the outer walls of the maze there
will always be Estelle cobbling riding
an undead stell horse
are these the resurrected remains of
Harry
I found another abandoned campsite very
similar to the one inside the North Loma
labyrinth with the same makeshift flag
campfire and this decayed piece of cloth
in my video about the labyrinth I refer
to this as the possible remains of a
tent but on closer inspection this
doesn't seem to be the case it's
basically a mattress made from pieces of
cloth and some straw other survivalists
out there are using the same method I'm
not 100% sure what the flag is for but
my best guess would be that it serves as
either a beacon or functions as a
weather vane to detect bad weather some
of the other Hylian travelers and even
some stables also have one of these
flags set up which leads me to believe
that this person was most likely a
Hylian unlike some of the other
abandoned campsites where the tent is
still present this person may have
survived this temporary hold up and
packed up their tent and moved on
whoever this person is or was they
definitely have a massive set of balls
on them as the location of this camp
site isn't exactly conventional it's
next to Hyrule Castle right smack in the
middle of the castle town ruins the
castle town watchtower to be exact I
mean this place is crawling with
Guardian stalkers and there's malice
everywhere this campsite was undoubtedly
set up after the great calamity since it
wouldn't make sense to build a camp
inside of a watchtower which is still
intact
so who is this mystery camper well the
answer can be found south of hyrule
castle at the wetland stable I think
this daredevil is none other than this
woman named Parsi she's actually tied to
a side quest called the Royal Guards
gear where you have to show her a piece
of equipment from the Royal Guard series
either a bow a shield sword claymore or
halberd anything will do
Parsi admits that she herself used to
sneak into hyrule castle to look for
this equipment but never managed to find
any she also states that hyrule castle
used to be a lot less dangerous than it
is now
zelda seal on calamity Ganon slowly
weaken the castle became more and more
of a risk to visit as a matter of fact
it's pretty much confirmed that people
used to go into the ruins of Hyrule
Castle to investigate more back in the
day as rumor mill vol 7 tells the story
of King Rome's secret room and Zelda's
laboratory also known as Princess Zelda
study
something no-one but the royal family
insiders could have known about
nonetheless getting into hyrule castle
all by yourself to look for some Royal
Guards gear spending the night inside
the ruins of castle town
this woman has my respect a true display
of bravery hearing a story about
something is one thing but actually
finding proof like this makes the world
all the more believable and it goes to
show how much little details the zelda
team have hidden around Hyrule there are
many more examples of abandoned camping
spots with little stories attached to
them like hearing someone in Llewelyn
say that monsters have been taking up
the best fishing spots only to find an
empty campsite on the shoreline on the
other side of the mountains with pikarin
scouring through the remains discovering
a tent with a set of snow walls near a
secret stone door into the mountains
indicating that someone else already
tried to solve this mystery but was
interrupted and had to leave their
venture behind hearing the stories of a
lone adventurer who tried to reach the
northern edge of Habra but was forced to
turn back because of bad weather and
strong winds ho because you wanted to
know what was there or how about the
mystery visitor on the equally
mysterious hard-to-reach makar island
who left behind nothing but a campfire
under a dead tree link isn't the only
one out there looking for answers a big
shout-out goes to Tim Demong an amazing
musician and fellow dutchy who provided
the Clock Town theme you heard that the
beginning of the video there's much more
where that came from so please go over
to his channel and show this man some
love the link is in the description and
of course a massive thanks to each and
every one of you for 10,000 subscribers
that is bananas I'll hold on bananas if
anyone would have told me one month ago
I would reach this number by June I
would have called them crazy this
milestone came a bit too fast to include
something special in this video but I
can still see if I can do something
special for next week if you have any
suggestions about what you want to see
that can steer my decision feel free to
share them down in the comments and that
is all for now next week we're gonna go
dungeon crawling again so I hope you
will join me on this adventure have a
great rest of your weekend
this is dawn signing off and have a good
one
you